this is Startalk every scientist you
talk to I don't care what their
particular concentration if they know
anything about science they're not
hopeful no one says you know what it's
gonna be great you know I mean people
need to wake up and realize that every
single scientific mind in the world
basically says hey you know what we
might be in trouble bill are you hopeful
because you know you're our last hope
here I'm always optimistic if you're not
optimistic you're not going to take
action and get things done
but I say it's going to be a close call
and this is not an extraordinary claim
it's going to be a tough nut to crack
so what we want to do is have a fee for
carbon carbon dioxide production and
then we will return the feet of the
people power to the people because I
don't know Bill's a communist yeah yeah
now that I know nothing for inviting
them on the show but here's the trouble
I could hear Ted Cruz right okay here's
the trouble where's the model for this
collect using wealth from the public and
redistributing it to the people well I
don't know don't they call that
socialism yeah and where is it in the
United States Alaska Alaska has the
Alaska never reverse income tax that's
yeah that's right yeah okay so stasis
own the state makes money what my wife
came from Alaska that's yeah yeah so
every family gilliam it's like $1,000
per I don't know what is now where it's
1,800 yeah in her day was a thousand
dollars per member of the family which
also meant you might want to have more
babies but it's per year and this is the
it's called it's a tax a negative tax
rate for their oil profits like a
production fund yes okay so we could do
this and this would provide economic
incentives which i think is the key to
getting our done to keep it in the
capitalist motivated not just that so
people who make a lot of carbon dioxide
they should be rich people who live high
on the hog as David Attenborough
described it where the meat is strong
and properly marbled and then
the middle-class would get the money
back oil companies fossil fuel companies
already have this built in they're
anticipating a $40 a ton surcharge
that's in their economic modeling it's
cool we could if we did this and then
the countries that don't produce carbon
dioxide and output this is a salt this
is not everything's going to be fine it
is part of the solution so bill for
presidents economic advisor that's what
your yeah this is not an extraordinary
claim and it's not really mine it makes
sense you're not gonna say it's from a
libertarian point of view this is
Startalk